hello and welcome to this video playing
tap course again yeah FN I didn't really
recognize that it was disappoint and I
would have probably played them played
something else
evil or immediately against those
against those kind of setup this is just
more powerful
efore d4f form I don't get it and you
have a like a lost position after 10
moves here why is it not lost
is there something great now for the two
ponds and get some development going
hmm okay get this back mommy gets this
back not really possible to keep the
ball
wasn't maybe even the best way to punish
this crazy stuff
this is close to compensation it's
really weird but it's close to
compensation
okay wants to cheek
yeah it's it's two pawns yeah it's true
it can take c5 I mean what did I do here
Queen a4 is just totally stupid
it's just totally stupid
really weird
yeah the blackest of course is better
here with the bishop pair for nothing
but what did I do with there was this
opening that was so so weird I wonder -
pants but it's somehow it didn't just
didn't work it just didn't work in a way
that you would expect it to work
okay so 95 I have to do this first
I don't want to defend this passive limb
and I just recognize I mean what is he
playing now rook c8 wasn't very good
just double check so okay so Knight
sorry let's do it like this so in this
one
so Bishop takes rook e8 check and then
97 is he thinking about here
I mean rook takes 97 is just totally
lost I mean this may be as well but
maybe there is Bishop g4 to make it to
make it weird at least or this is
comparable so I don't have only have
this this is not technically super easy
because the bishops are so strong I have
to make sure that I don't blunder the
night for example that can easily happen
and I've got 14 seconds my bishops are
immensely strong cannot attack the
knight now so I will get a 6 but getting
the knight back to a safe safe square
won't be easy like to e3 or something
maybe 94 was good but okay Gary taking
this pawn shouldn't be bad
or just this
five seconds
if was a good one night therefore
I don't have much time not entirely
certain that this is a winner that would
be helpful now to to be fantastic at
theoretical ending of theoretical
endings at least I can play this quite
quickly it could be a drone
it's very likely drawn this is
definitely a draw like theoretically
speaking but still has to be played 11
seconds
yeah can happen minutes it's it's
certainly somehow the correct result and
in a way but yeah
Darrin still cannot get all those and I
can play this yes three three minutes
six seconds on the clock and it's double
pawn sacrifice like just like whoosh and
first I don't know why it somehow works
but it does so 95 yeah and I'm doing
this too quickly like because I think
it's so ridiculous that I play instantly
and this is stronger even then it's not
a total win forward surprisingly I mean
it basically blunders to bonds and it's
not not winning immediately 96 and
somehow it's got some compensation him
even for two points yeah it's just zero
point something okay the engine is not
very deep you know it yeah this is not
really great I mean it's just weird you
good two points but he's got excellent
development and he I recognized that
things are not really that great I
didn't play well now and I should maybe
have some way to be equal not that I see
it that just like on general grounds and
here he is just fine very fine now I'm
basically try to get somehow get it raw
in this bad position a six I was
surprised I don't know why he would play
a six and weaken the Queen
kids it's not a huge deal I guess now
I'm kind of getting a bit of activity
and this is just don't don't
this isn't good right okay king - king
g7 King G separate us just hold
everything together I can take and it
then it's very dry now again now I'm
winning material oops sorry I didn't
want to do that it was still not easy
because of the time this is this this we
did this is probably fairly simple you
know in a long time control but the way
way it it went it was it was it was
tricky yeah I shouldn't trade here
problem I was thinking I'm getting more
on that side of the board okay this is a
good one here
gen-i th5 was now mostly because I had
no time I mean I knew that it is
probably not objectively best but you
know that you're not going to blunder it
away or something
I hope be six is not actually so
difficult because this is not a good a
good way to do it yeah after this I
think it's probably objectively a draw
it's probably wrong yeah this is
something where you need to have studied
to read skis and get menu or three times
and you maybe know what this is I
suspect it's a draw but yeah we have
seen you can as possibilities blunder
okay guys thanks for watching